daniel gélin après coup de jeune réalisé
par votre fils davy vous la devenu un
spécialiste du premier âge alors vous
avez pour résumer le rôle d'un vieux
beau à l'élégance moustachu qui se
rebellent contre l'autorité et aussi
contre l'injustice
voilà c'est ça c'est un rôle charmant
délicieux qui aurait pu être vrai
d'ailleurs et j'ai adoré faire ce film
nous l'avons tout dans une ambiance de
folie et quand même de grande vigilance
je pensais à écouter les nouvelles de ce
soit je m'aperçois vraiment qu'on fait
un très très beau métier lorsque ceux ci
à distraire les gens est allé ferrer et
avec l iran plus de qualité puisque le
geiq forcé n'insinue toujours tu veux
tendresse un petit peu de l'élégance de
façon de raconter des choses
nous avons procédé aventure formidable
je pense que là le rire que nous avons
que nous avons eu en tout dans le film
sera contagieux que les les auditeurs
les spectateurs seront vivifiée par la
vision de ce film on en a tous besoin
vous pouvez nous chanter un peu gras
vous êtes venu inspecter ça le côté
jacques français m'a reproché dans le
film lorsque je danse que je dansais
trop bien mais là le rap ça non piège
des mamys formidable s'enrichir
extraordinaire fantastique c'était toute
l'histoire du cinéma plancher plus noir
l'éternel blondeur fraîcheur santé
chaniol gisèle casadesus maurice baquet
à qui jacques force elle a eu le culot
de donner le rôle d'un firme alors qu'il
escaladait encore la face du mont blanc
non ça a été c'est un film très joyeux
dit la vivifie jean carmet vous n'avez
jamais joué avec lui longtemps on a dit
reviens de carrière examiner tous les
deux voir moi j'ai soixante deux ans lui
veut pas dire qu'il les a mais il se
soit souvent devant lui oui je sais pas
je vous avais raconté ça tout à l'heure
que ça va le faire évoluer les choses
poursuit face à baho bull a terrorisé il
va faire un petit peu attention et l
orne on se connaissait depuis depuis
quand elle avait 17 ans n'avait
pratiquement jamais travaillé ensemble
en avait beaucoup ri beaucoup ri on en
est là c'est une rencontre on était
tellement près l'un de l'autre que je
dis je pensais que si la nature nous
avait considéré autrement
je pense que dans la sphère très jolie
ménages roulez jeunesse un très très
jolie fille de jacques fansten vous vous
êtes un vrai sage de continuer à
cultiver vos routes oui j'y vais demain
gb damas les rosés
bien d'autres choses d'accord merci
beaucoup je vais vous demander quelques
conseils horticoles dans un instant 25
ans